si vous laissez c'est une décision
politique ça me gêne profondément si
c'est une décision rationnelle liée à
une sécurité qui pourraient être
défaillante ou et des investissements
trop gros de maintenance ce qui peut
être une bonne raison en disant il faut
démanteler à son moulin je me rallier la
décision genèse avant de gérer gens vont
penser que c'est une décision politique
aulas et je pense que c'est une décision
malheureusement très politique et ça me
gêne en effet alors après je ne
connaisse pas le suffisamment le dossier
pour vous donner un avis circonstancié
d'accord est ce que vous croyez à une
reconversion du site comme le dit
aujourd'hui ségolène royal qui parle
d'un choix positif pour ce qui est sûr
soul et c'est que dans toutes les
reconversions du sinn
il faut trouver des systèmes pour
réembaucher les personnes ça peut être
dans le cas du nucléaire toute une
filière de démantèlement de sécurité de
démantèlement d' optimisation d'énergie
renouvelable tout ce qui est énergie
climat c'est développement durable sont
des filières d'avenir
donc je pense qu'en effet si vraiment la
décision et confirmer qu'elle est
rationnelle
il faut et bien continuer bien
évidemment de travailler sur la sur
l'emploi et idéalement le cas là si la
décision irrationnelle mais vous nous
avez dit que vous pensez plutôt à une
décision politique voulue par françois
hollande il veut c dont ils ont
programmé leur recette de moi mais ce
avant de quitter si ces avancées non
après regardons comment ce cette
décision c'est très décision évolué dans
le temps on va comme justement alors si
il ya une décision politique pour
essayer de précipiter la fermeture vous
espérer un revirement cas d'alternance
politique moi je crois qu'il faut
regarder ce dossier encore une fois je
connais pas en profondeur il faut
regarder le coup le coût de la
maintenance pourquoi on le ferme
exactement si on est fait 7 7 filles
avec trop vieille et le coût de la foule
a prolongé coûterait une forte mais le
coup il a déjà été engagé il ya eu des
travaux importants ont été engagés cette
centrale de fessenheim ces dernières
années
oui après je ne sais pas on amène aux
normes alors d'accord il ya mise aux
normes et puis ensuite à l'exploitation
par année bon soit c'est rationnel et
les voilà soit c'est pas rationnel si
ces politiques ça me gêne on a cassé ses
politiques ça vous gêne et vous dites
aux politiques que le nucléaire est un
atout pour l'économie
enfin les allemands c'est un atout ce
sont des investissements énormes que
nous avons fait c'est c'est une honte
c'est une énergie propre décarbonée
maintenant lorsqu'on a fait
l'investissement c'est quand même idiot
de supprimer vous considérez que par
exemple le nucléaire aujourd'hui 75% de
la production électrique ça vous va très
bien comme pourcentage mais je crois
qu'il faut évoluer vers un mix soul il
faut pas être tout nucléaire non plus il
faut en effet à arriver sur les énergies
renouvelables sur 20 ans sacrifient rue
charles en investissant sur sa faim en
capitalisant sur ses gros
investissements que nous avons est fait
depuis 30 ou 40 ans